- I like knowing that I
can be there for people
without actually being there.
That's a nice feeling.
I've always been a very
honest, open, writer.
I've always wore my heart on my sleeve.
My voice is my instrument,
so sometimes I sing
things that sound crazy,
but then like one take out of 20
will be really, really cool.
- Hello Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from Grammy award-winning
singer and songwriter Ellie Goulding,
and my take on her top
ten rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down
in the comments below,
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple of hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(jet engine)
(upbeat music)
- Often fans tell me that the music I make
has helped them through things
with their family and their friends,
and boyfriend/girlfriend.
Help them reconcile with their
father or mother, or whoever.
That's quite a nice feeling,
that my music can do that.
♫ 'Cause this is devotion, I am ...
I like knowing that I
can be there for people
without actually being there.
That's a nice feeling.
I can't even be there for my own family,
let alone my fans.
So it's nice I can produce
something that is comforting.
♫ Break, I'll fix it for you.
♫ I'm the one who drives to you at night
♫ And maybe we'll fall a little deeper
♫ I think our little
hearts will be alright
♫ 'Cause this is devotion
♫ This is devotion
My writing style has
always been very hopeful.
I don't like writing depressing songs,
unless I can offer some
kind of resolution.
And that's just how I've always written.
Even when I used to
write poetry and essays,
and shit when I was young.
I write my songs in a very specific way.
Like even if they're about someone.
It will never be like, ooh that's about;
you know like it would never be;
It's never like shade or burn,
or any of that kind of stuff.
I don't believe in that.
I believe in; I write songs,
I like to write songs with a resolution.
I like to write songs always
with something positive.
So even if I write about
somebody that's broken my heart,
or somebody that's hurt me,
or a situation I've been
in that's been unpleasant.
I still want to try and write like a poet.
I still want to write
something that is timeless.
Like Shakespeare.
I want to write things
that sound true forever.
I see the good in everyone,
and I see the good in everything,
and I think that there's
always a silver lining
and there's always good
to come out of everything.
So if you notice my lyrics,
there's always a resolution of some kind.
There's always an everything
is going to be okay moment.
So even if I have been in situations
where I think that was really unfair,
that was mean,
or I was hurt by something.
I always try and do it
in a way that resolves it
in my own head.
I think that; I think that
as a writer I've progressed.
I've always been a very
honest, open writer.
I've always worn my heart on my sleeve,
the way that I write
lyrics, and tell stories.
Without wanting to sound like a cliche,
I genuinely like being very honest
and being real about my situation,
about my childhood, about my past.
It kind of contributes to what I write,
and what I do as an artist.
So I think it's important to shed light
on what I've been through and stuff.
And I never; I always feel
weird if I leave stuff out,
and fans are left not
knowing stuff about me.
I'd like them to to
kind of know everything.
I did listen to a bit of Joni Mitchell.
Did listen to; I have
listened to a lot of Feist.
My Brightest Diamond,
and I love the (mumbles)
I really like their lyrics.
And suddenly I realized
that you could be quirky,
but you could also still be quite poppy.
My mom constantly listened
to pop and dance music.
So it was very pop,
and I wasn't introduced to any old bands.
I was discovering music by myself.
So it was kind of a discovery;
it was me discovering things
that would allow me to
find out about older
bands and older singers.
Maybe it could be that I
have a very kind of unique
sort of way, in that I've
listened to a hell of a lot
of quite obscure folk music, and Bjork.
But then I also really love pop music.
But I refuse to let one of
them overtake the other.
So I think that's why I
seem to have been given this
appreciation in blocks.
Sort of a more of an Indie area.
And then also I seem to have
this sort of pop thing as well.
I guess my lyrics are just
really important to me.
I never want them to be
too alien and complicated,
but I want them to have a meaning always.
It's like it's always finding
the right kind of balance
in my songs of surreal stuff
and then very real stuff
that's very universal and relatable.
So for me it's always finding
that balance within my tracks.
I write things on my laptop a lot.
And now that I've got a laptop.
And I write on my phone.
I write on paper.
It depends sometimes;
I kind of have to be in a
certain frame of mind to write.
I have to be; sometimes
I have to be quite down,
sometimes I have to be really elated.
But generally, it's me
coming up with some chords
and some words, and something
I really want to write about,
something I need to get off my chest.
- What do you think that
this panel is seeing in you,
they have decided that you hit the moment.
- I don't know.
And I wish I did, because
it would be a lot easier.
I suppose I'm quite normal,
and I wasn't necessarily ambitious
so I guess I don't really
have a business kind of mind.
So in that way my music ends up being;
I hate using this word, but quite organic
in that I write things;
I just go after it blind
and just hope for the best.
And that's how I've always worked.
I sort of like to do things in the moment.
So if I have a resolution I want to make,
I just kind of do it.
Actually, you know,
I want to be a bit more
adventurous next year.
As in I want to be a bit
more of an adventure seeker,
do some skydives and stuff.
But I don't think I can do a bungee jump.
I think that's a bit too far.
- You can skydive, but
you couldn't bungee jump.
- I think it's very different.
Bungee jumping you throw yourself off.
At least skydive, someone's
going to (mumbles)
and that's that, and
just takes you with them.
I think bungee jumping is
a while different thing.
But I think I want to do
things that kind of scare me,
and get over my fears
a bit more next year.
So maybe I do have some New
Year's resolutions actually.
I've been supporting Bruno Mars,
and I supported quite a
few artists in arenas,
so I feel like I've been
lucky in that respect
because I've built a
stamina that's required
of playing such big shows,
but they haven't been my shows,
so the pressure's been off.
So I've been able to practice
playing to lots of people,
but like I said the
pressure is off in that
it's not my own show, and
I can sort of, I dunno.
It's definitely easier
supporting someone in an arena.
Like the crowd is not
necessarily there to support you,
but you can win them over.
It makes you realize that you have to
put on a really special show,
to get people's favor.
So I've been able to do that.
And then my own shows; I go
back and do my own shows,
and I sort of replicate
what I do in arenas,
and it makes the show a bit bigger,
and a bit more special.
- What is it like as a
writer, as a musician,
at a time when there is this.
I mean once upon a
time, I'm showing my age
I apologize, but I can't help it.
Something like you would have come along,
and in a way there would
have been one of it,
maybe two.
Whereas now, and not to say
they're exactly the same,
but you know what I'm saying,
there can be a lot of the
same kind of thing, of peers.
So I wondered how difficult it is for you
to try and generate
the kind of originality
that you really want to have.
- Well I think the important
thing is not to try.
And hopefully you don't have to try.
And luckily I feel like I've been given
that kind of advantage,
in that I feel like I'm
not trying hard to create
something that's original.
But because I have such
a passion for folk music,
and music which is so simple and beautiful
with just a guitar,
that it just so happens that
I've constructed my songs
that way without thinking
about it too much.
Not putting too much, this
song has to be different
but it also has to be mainstream
so that I sell records.
It's completely not like that.
It's just the fact that myself
and my producer Starsmith,
he's the same age,
and he has a passion for electronic music.
I have a passion for
folk music in particular.
But we also listen to a
lot of the same things
when we were younger.
So we just go into a
session and slowly start to
construct a song, and I
usually already have the
kind of the backbone for it.
But I think it's easy
enough for me to say this,
but I think the best
thing is not to try hard,
because you can almost tell.
I think that's why the
break of connection between
you and your listeners,
that's when the break comes
because they can't connect.
'Cause they can almost sense
that it's like too try hard or whatever.
It's key to everything,
or it's key to what I do.
I wouldn't be here without
experimenting like crazy.
I like so many different types of music,
and I hope that I could
get away with including
all of those different
influences on my first record.
And I think I got away with it.
And maybe on my second as well.
But I mean like, I would
say that I'm a pop artist,
I make pop music.
But it's not without a
lot of experimentation
and also risking writing something
that maybe isn't very good,
or is silly.
My voice is my instrument
so sometimes I sing things
that just sound crazy,
but then one take out of 20 will be
really, really cool, and
then I keep that one.
Then that's that.
So yeah, experimentation
is everything for me
as a musician, yeah.
- When I tweeted today
that you were going to
do another interview,
we got all kinds of questions.
One of them was, how do you feel about
so many people remixing Starry Eyes?
- Well a lot of people have remixed that,
and a lot of people have remixed;
Ones that just kind of
blown up out of nowhere,
and it's amazing.
I love hearing my song
with a completely different feel to it.
I love the idea that my
vocal can just be put
onto pretty much anything.
- Lights has been remixed by
every single artist right now.
On the planet, it seems like.
Do you have a favorite version?
- Bassnectar remix has
always been my favorite.
He's like my big brother, Lorin.
It's so funny how the remix
started off our friendship,
but it really kick started
Lights in the States.
'Cause at first when Lights started having
some kind of prominence in America,
it was always like, "Oh yo,
I love the Bassnectar remix."
At first, and then all of a
sudden Lights just creeping
up and it had its own journey.
So yeah, there's probably about
1,000 Lights remixes out now.
I'm not even joking.
It's the most remixed
song probably of all time.
I've been probably the most
remixed artist in the UK.
For some reason I'm
just like, that's okay.
But then some I listen to,
I think that is better than the original.
And I really fall in love with them.
Like a guy from Monsieur Adi from France,
remixed Guns and Horses,
and it just blew me away.
I thought, God it sounded
like it was supposed to be
at the end of a film.
Like some epic, a love story,
because it was amazing.
It made me cry a little bit.
It's almost like it
wasn't my song anymore.
It was just an amazing thing
that someone had created.
I've read a lot since I was young,
so books inspire me,
like (mumbles), poetry.
I've read a lot of poetry
over the last few years.
And I like kind of dark, like
funny, kind of humorous stuff.
I read a big book of
poems at Staying Alive,
a compilation of poems.
They're like real and
raw, and quite explicit.
And so I used those.
Obviously like other singers
of the band, musicians,
I like classical music.
I listen to so much stuff
that I'm just kind of
inundated all the time.
So that's kind of how I work really.
Listen to a lot of music all the time.
Now it's just, internet
is used by so many people,
and there's so much downloading
that it's become the way.
And more people are getting iPods,
more people are finding their music.
And so it's kind of they're more attracted
to internet stuff.
I guess there's more
ways of finding music.
You can get things like Track in a Box.
You get a track sent to you every day.
And you find out things that way.
And me personally, I do feel like
there's so much music,
it's impossible for me
as a maker of new music,
to be completely aware of everything.
I just go on random recommendations
that people give me,
and I might discover something for myself.
But I think that's the best way,
because you can get just inundated with;
you just get so much stuff thrown at you.
I can beat box.
- Oh yeah, well forget that.
- A little bit, probably
not as good, I dunno.
- Go ahead, try.
(beat boxing)
- That was a little one.
- Oh no.
- It's getting that.
(beat boxing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Shailendra Einstein asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
and their future top ten,
please check out the link
down in the description below,
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Marta Magdalena.
Marta thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting that
awesome message on Twitter.
I'm so glad that you're coming
back to it and rereading it
whenever you're having moments of doubt.
I really appreciate that,
and for sharing it as well.
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much,
and I'm really happy you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(jet engine)
- How have your (mumbles) going?
Your sound's evolved a
lot since the first album.
How's it been taken?
- It's pretty good.
The second album has
gotten me around the world,
and gotten me some, I dunno,
to go some cool places.
It's definitely, I think
everything's evolved.
Like I've managed to sort of,
get worldwide a bit more,
and tour places I've never toured before.
And it's all evolved in general.
Like touring, and the
records, and just everything.
I don't know really.
I feel like I do work really hard,
but I sort of stay at a level
that I'm really
comfortable and happy with.
I genuinely never wanted
to be a superstar.
I just didn't.
It just never really occurred to me
that that would ever be possible.
I'm grateful for everyday,
because I get to support
Bruno, fricking, Mars on tour.
I just don't understand it.
So long as I have that,
which I do everyday,
I just have the best time.
I get to write songs and
put them on a record.
Some people buy them,
and some people don't.
I have a really fun time with it.
The biggest thing I probably go to,
if I'm kind of in a rush, is Hype Machine.
I go on Hype Machine a lot.
I go on EARMILK, (mumbles) quite a lot.
But you know, I feel like I'm very lucky,
because I've been connected
with so many producers and DJs
just from remixes and
from working with people,
and having such an affinity
with electronic music.
I get to meet people,
and people send me stuff.
I have connections with a lot of people.
So yeah, just 'cause I've been doing it
for such a long time.
The first people that I
reached out to on MySpace
for the electronic producers
Barrio and Frank Music,
and a bunch of people; Roscoe.
So I've been; I think
that people appreciate
that I have that connection
with electronic music
and just my love of so many
different types of music.
'Cause it led me to that.